Psalm 100 had one of the craziest First
episodes in anime we all know the zombie
apocalypse Trope zombies suddenly appear
in the world they started killing off
the human population and turning them
into zombies and people struggled to
survive in an environment that becomes
more dangerous by the minute it's a
horrifying concept your friends and
neighbors and everyone you know turning
into monsters who want to devour you
Society collapses this is horror right
well zom 100 is totally different the
main character is an overworked salary
man who hates his job so much that he
would rather die than keep working there
so when the zombie apocalypse happens
this guy is actually happy everything is
collapsing all around him but he's just
excited not to have to go to work
anymore he decides to live it up while
the world Burns around him and I have to
say that so far I'm digging this anime
for more anime content subscribe to
anime outboard right now